in Afghanistan the announcement that
women could not attend University
brought protesters to the street that
and a ban on women working with
International Aid organizations brought
a new round of global condemnation for
the Taliban it what happened recently in
the recent measures by
the Taliban government in Afghanistan
has been very disappointing for us and
we've been warning them from taking such
a decisions that are going to just to
make the situation much worse for the
Afghan people but also for the
International Community to be able to
deal with them the Taliban restored the
ability of women to work with
International ngos after several Aid
organizations said they could not or
would not carry out badly needed
humanitarian work without them but the
UN says that isn't enough
the U.N security Council has repeatedly
called for the rights of Afghan women
and girls to be restored and now the
un's most powerful woman deputy
secretary General Amina Muhammad herself
a Muslim is in Afghanistan to make the
case along the way she's Enlisted the
help of several Muslim countries and
organizations
clear consensus was evident on the issue
of women's and girls rights
to work and have access to education
there was a broad sense that the region
and the organization of the Islamic
conference's leadership on these issues
was critical and needed to be
strengthened with the full support and
collaboration of the International
Community
Afghanistan's neighbors say the
International Community can't walk away
from the struggling country or its women
the Muslim world has moved on from such
uh from from this approach and we pride
ourselves uh on on the progress that
you're seeing across the Muslim World
vis-a-b women's rights but the solution
is to engage the Afghan government and
try and convince them to live up to
their expect their their Promises to the
International Community uh and that is
exactly the Pakistan's approach an
approach all the more crucial for Afghan
women as Taliban attempt to take away
their ability to be seen or heard
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the United
Nations